every time I get to come on the ship I
have a great time good except when
people say that I bully Cody the whole
time because I don't you bully everyone
no no no no I like having nice
conversations with friends and that's
what I do here you do and then they
always force me out whenever these
cameras go let me tell you something and
I'll be honest about this this whole
production here the [__] 45 people in
the back you guys got yeah as soon as
I'm done they could not boot me out the
[__] door yeah we don't we don't
touch them as soon as they're like hey
what's going by as soon as it's done we
use a 15-foot pole with a yeah push me
out yeah with a sock on the end of it
just so we don't bruise him and we're
like get out get out
yeah yeah you know he's got soft white
skin we don't want to leave any black
and blue on there so we just [__] get
known I have a big bruise on my thigh I
don't know how I got it
do you just wake up with them
maybe I'm wrestling some demons in my
sleep apparently
[Laughter]
yeah
my uh my wife keeps waking me up
recently because of my sleep apnea oh
bro get a CPAP machine immediately I
need to I guess it's one of those things
where I'm like choking for air yeah you
cannot died horrible she wakes me out
she's like you're snoring's terrible I'm
like would you just leave me the [__]
alone I'm trying to sleep do that kind
of thing and then she recorded me and it
was like brutal
like I was like I'm gonna die yeah this
is a heart attack waiting to happen get
a CPAP machine it's a whole thing though
you know you know I hate going to the I
hate going to the doctor as an
overweight man hate going to the doctor
yo get over it you know because they
always say they always say this you know
what they always say they say this they
always say you got a lot of changes to
make uh do what yeah oh do I dog thanks
for the [__] bill dude yeah and they
can never just like give you the stuff
there they have to go to a specialist
and stuff who has the time I'll I'll
hold your hand I'll hold your fat little
hand through this whole process full of
[__] I hope you're I'll hold your gummy
fat hand through this process so you get
a goddamn CPAP machine because you ever
have to I want you to be on this Earth I
want you to be on this Earth you ever
have to come at the doctor do I have to
no have you ever had like come at the
doctor no no have you yeah for what well
check out fertility yes wow because when
I was 14 an artery went going down to my
balls this is real or do I go going down
to my testicle got twisted and my my
nuts swelled up until I'm not even
joking the size of a softball it was
insane I showed everybody yeah my buddy
showed up he's like why are you hobbling
around I just had I always have
basketball shorts on just pop it out
real quick boom look like a baby's pinky
just draped over a basketball right what
it looked like and I sat there and it
was so painful I sat there and I was
holding it in my hand kind of like uh
sourmon and Lord of the Rings Two Towers
because that [__] ball he's like
yeah that's how I was hold it and I had
to go to and this is the worst part I
was just old enough to be really
self-conscious about your body your dick
size and everything yeah they put me in
Children's Mercy Hospital okay all right
so here I am laying down just in extreme
pain getting that morphine tap and then
the peach squat comes in smoking hot
doctors hey we just need to look at that
then they're looking at my tiny little
[__] giant balls yeah and I'm like
they're poking around slapping it doing
all kinds of [__] 10 minutes goes by
we're part of the red Squad another
super hot doctor all kinds of it wasn't
miserable right but anyways I have like
a eight percent chance fertility so wow
I just killed it wow and you want to
know the worst part that was me with my
balls
that was me look that was me whenever I
didn't know the severity of the
situation I was like look at it my
friend's like oh my god dude that's
horrifying I'm like I know it actually
looked like a monkey's brain yeah I
would hold it I mean it was insane yeah
because it was so large and lumpy I mean
it was [__] crazy you think skin
doesn't stretch it does it's [__]
crazy but they sat there and uh
um the worst part about it though as I
had AC DC tickets couldn't go
did you write them a letter yes your
show because my balls got yeah my ball
was huge I was in pain I couldn't see it
hey rock on fellas
you know I finally he's quite the
emotional story we should get him out
for a shower this kid right here is
Bulls swelled up to the size of a
baseball
he'll never be able to use the
impression got it do an AC DC impression
I can do like Back in Black five
sounds just like it I've never I've
never listened to ACDC just do what I do
it sounds good that's good dude
I'm glad to be back I can't do that just
try it I can't why what do you mean you
can't I've been real this whole episode
I'll be real with you right now I can't
do that
what's a what's uh
I just want you to do another impression
honestly oh my just like a little
impression monkey to you well it's just
almost dead
got a little Texas Two Step around that
one and say new
yeah monkey little feet no no no no no I
think Hunter's called me a monkey I'm
ballet dancing around that I've never
said that I just want to hear you do
give me one what's one impression you
think you can do because I know you
definitely think you can do one I
actually don't I think I'm like just I
can do a variety of mid Impressions
that's fine well then what's the mid
impression you got
give me what you think like Robert
Downey Jr sounds like
um Jarvis how can I get my dick sucked
right now there you go I I would I would
accept that okay
I'm just coming at it from this
perspective like oh if I did a cartoon
would he be able to do that oh
so why don't you try the AC DC One
You're now you're loosened up
so Back In Black I had the sags been too
long I'm glad to be back
oh dude you can do Shoot to Thrill
what a Kill
too many women with too many pills
I think we just got it I think that was
good
whatever dude I think you know I try to
sit there because you know what I was
wanting to do is record it I was going
to take it and I was going to record
music behind it and be like Noah Miller
in AC DC and I thought that would be a
lot of fun for me
that would have been a lot of fun for me
what if I send you like a high quality
can you sing good not really
do uh say like a Justin Timberlake song
my voice doesn't do that okay
like you would do a good Johnny Cash do
98 year old Johnny Cash
to see if I still feel something like
that it was good yeah you don't have a
lot of confidence when you're doing it
though it's like so this isn't Fun
like I was like I thought that this
would be like like I'm like we're
getting ready to bond
oh you kind of took that from me because
you're not taking it seriously you're
kind of just like that's what it is it
is what it is though let's see that's
what I'm saying I can't really sing you
just did you just didn't sound too bad
yeah I never really Doug though
musically Bruno Mars
you heard Luke's feelings with that it's
okay dude he's like okay what Bruno shut
the [__] up fat man have you heard
grenade have you heard grenade that last
record he did the soul record was fun
yeah but all the other stuff Sonic is
All the yeah that was that was just fun
yeah the other stuff I don't know that's
just basketball what was the big big
song that came out like 2013 oh 24 Karat
distance
don't believe me just watch
yeah yeah 24 Karat every single is that
what it's called 24 Karat 24 Karat Magic
yeah
the amount of times I heard my mom
listen to that song
was unbelievable you see my latest
upload uh not what happened you like
that
wow look at that friend
first you can't pick me up from the
airport they don't even watch the first
video I did let me see
last one I watched was Velma I was
laughing
he's a patreon plug let me say John push
right there see I even animated myself
YouTube is killing me YouTube is killing
me good good title for a video dude
Susan was like no well I saw your the
teasing of the Susan images so yeah
actually play a little bit of it just
because the uh the first part you have
to be creative of ways that you can get
around doing like titties and [__] and
ass and stuff like that yeah so in this
one
sit there and when she comes up it's
like her titties a little monetization
can canister
so see you sit there and now she's able
to grab her titty off that's fun smart
isn't that fun there's Mr Beast
he gets he gets first pickings let this
go all the way
all right that's it no no Let It Go Let
It Go no no actually if anything only go
skip a little head to the Sailor Moon
transformation part
keep going keep going keep going keep
going
uh like right there the power the
support
my god dude
holy [__] childhood flashbacks right now
this is hysterical brother watch this
out
[Laughter]
shoe anymore
my create
they can live off the lane
you must confide by my rules
how lovely is that dude it's beautiful
isn't that fun look at those thighs dude
damn
that's like you in real life that's why
I have dreary like that this is chunky
it's true I like cottage cheese dude
man my ass is unpleasant I I do need to
make some changes
I'm still yeah you want me to be real
dude you really need to get a [__]
CPAP machine okay I'm not gonna let you
live that down whatever Mom yeah
[Music]
hey hey come on man yeah when you die
from [__] sleep apnea I'm gonna go to
your funeral and been like if only
Hunter had Chantix to save him I will
I'm going to get it actually I'm just
gonna throw a pack of Chantix in your
[__] casket and be like take that
[__] with you I would love that
I hope my coffin is full of Jack
Daniel's Enchantix